some young Costa Rican basileus lizards
are looking for food basilisks have been
nicknamed the Jesus Christ lizard why
this adult male probably the father of
the young wizards can't tell us nor can
this female exclusive property of the
territorial male it has nothing to do
with the feeding habits of the basilisk
which consists primarily of insects and
berries this predatory reptile will help
reveal the secret as it stalks the young
basilisk
[Music]
the basilisk is called the Jesus Christ
lizard because it can walk Pam well
giving run on water it bicycles its hind
legs and the tail becomes a
counterweight we can't know what the
snake is thinking did it really want to
eat the lizard or did it just want to
show
[Music]